hogyan is lehet használni ezt a mind map
módszert arra hogy komplex gondolatokat
hogyan lehet megérteni és megjegyezni az
egy vizuális módszer ahol a különböző
fogalmaknak az egymáshoz vett relációját
meg tudjuk jegyezni és egymáshoz képes
hierarchikusan el tudjuk rendezni
ugyanis az történik sokszor hogy a
fejünkben az információ nincs rendezve
fragmentáltan jelenik meg mint például
akár egy meeting esetében is amikor
leülünk egy tárgyalás során beszélgetni
és két órán keresztül beszélget öt ember
ide-oda kalandozva nehéz megmondani
konkrétan miről is szólt az a a
megbeszélés ilyenkor
jegyzetelhetünk utólag igyekez
igyekezhetünk rekonstruálni hogy miről
beszélgettünk viszont nagyon hasznos
lenne hogyha valami vagy valaki össze
tudná számunkra fogadni foglalni hogy
miről szól miről szólt az a megbeszélés
és ilyenkor vizuálisan látnánk hogy
beszélgettünk erről a témáról ennek a
témának volt három altémája annak a
három altémának volt egyenként négyö
vagy egy másik téma és akkor volt egy
másik téma amiről beszélgettünk és
gyakorlatilag mint egy gráf a fejünkben
mint egy térkép úgy tudjuk majd átlátni
magát a megbeszélést